over and over again.
>> You're going to get us clipped. YOU
CAN'T ANSWER. THAT'S ALREADY DONE.
That's already finished. Listen, I'll be
honest. This you guys are to be the most
irrational people I've spoke in my life.
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> Yes.
>> And that's why I say yes.
>> Prove it. Prove it.
>> Okay. Prove that God. If you prove it,
prove option.
>> If you prove it, I'm going to become an
atheist. Prove
[Music]
>> I'm so happy to be able to talk to you
today and mashallah, my brother, our Ali
Ham is doing a great job. Work forever
is a very very uh beautiful cause
because the reward of what you give is
not just at the moment of giving but
rather it is prolonged for a very very
long time and it lasts for as long as
that work continues to generate to
generate some form of benefit. So I
highly recommend walk forever as an
ambassador of Abdullah Aid. I know the
the uh partnership that we have is
amazing and uh not many people
understand the concept of wak yet the
reward is far greater through the wak.
So inshallah if you can support walk
forever uh it will be really really
amazing and very very rewarding.
>> Is that your actual name or is that
>> my my actual name? My actual name is
Muhammad cubed.
>> Are you Are you Muslim?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> My actual name is Ralph.
>> Are you a Muslim?
>> Uh, no. I'm not religious.
>> What's your religion?
>> Ralph. No, you're religious.
>> Oh, no. No religion.
>> You're not a religion?
>> Atheist.
>> Okay. I can prove God exists in 2
minutes.
>> You can prove it. Oh, I can prove it.
>> I can prove God.
>> I would love to hear this.
>> I would love to. Okay. Good. Okay. What
I'm going to do is I'm going to Can I
Can I use your gloves as an example?
>> Of course.
>> Do you mind if I take him off? No. Okay.
Keep fine. All right. Turn it around.
>> Okay. Okay. Do you agree that your the
your gloves have a specific shape?
>> I'd agree with that. Yeah.
>> Okay. Do you agree that it has a
specific pattern on the inside?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Good. Does it have a purpose?
>> A purpose? Yes.
>> What's the purpose?
>> Keep my hands warm.
>> Okay. Good. Does it have a designer?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Good.
>> Would you say more?
>> Yeah. Designer I mean someone that made
it.
>> Yeah. Someone made it.
>> Okay. Good. Is your heart more complex
in design or your gloves?
>> My heart.
>> Okay. Good.
>> More complex.
>> Your heart is more complex. Yes. Good.
So if this has a purpose, if this has a
pattern, if this has a shape and it has
a designer, if your heart is more
complex and rationally logically follows
that some created your heart,
>> does that rationally follow you? What's
this called? This isn't a choir. This is
Thomas Paley's watchmaker theory.
>> Yeah.
>> Until I'm until I'm offered to talk.
So rational logically, does that follow?
>> Does it follow? I don't know if it does
follow. We have to be well
>> because the main the main argument
against this is that obviously yes the
heart is way more and the whole design
of nature is a lot more complex than
this glove. Obviously this glove has a
designer
>> made it for a purpose. Good.
>> So what's the purpose of your heart
>> exactly? The purpose of my heart is to
keep me alive.
>> Okay. Good.
>> The purpose of natur
who who made your heart the way it is so
it gives you life.
>> Evolution.
>> What do you mean by evolution? is
evolution is not a blind fear.
>> We're both in the interview. I want him
to him to judge.
>> No, it's fine. Before we get there, just
one second, please. Cuz you're a Muslim.
So when you say evolution, evolution is
not a blind process. Evolution.
Evolution. So is a blind process.
>> It is a blind process. But the thing
with evolution is that it came across so
much time. The point of evolution is
that with that much time that all the
random chances they kind of
>> No, it doesn't make sense. So what
you're doing is you're saying that if
you give it
>> okay let me let my brother go.
>> What you're using right now is a classic
GCSC argument. The watch maker and the
creator. If something so complex was
made it must had a creator. And that's
the default argument. You can use that
for anything. But exactly I'm going to
use your logic against yours. If you're
saying that something so complex was
created then what created that creator?
And exactly that it just goes back and
back and then and then and then no.
Okay. Please I promise you I'll shut up
in 2 seconds. The go-to argument after
that is that God is so defiant and so
naturally great that he doesn't need a
creator. He defies laws of physics. And
that right there is a complete void of
your argument. That's not my argument.
>> Okay, then I apologize. Perfect. So
let's so so let's go back to the basics.
Okay. Firstly, number one, I believe
that God Almighty is necessary and he's
independent. So I'll use the argument
from contingency. Yes. Firstly, the
example that I gave you is an evidence
that God exists. But I'll move to away
I'll add add an argument on top of that.
Number one, do you accept that there are
Okay, there are three t types of
existence, an impossible existence, a
possible existence, and a necessary
existence. Yes. So, I'll give you
examples of that.
>> I guess I'll accept that, but I don't
know.
>> I'll give you I'll give you examples.
Number one, an impossible existence is
like a triangle square or a married
bachelor.
>> Can't be possible.
>> Good. So, so it's an impossible
existence. It doesn't exist.
>> I'm honestly willing to learn here. I'm
not 100%.
So, we have two types of existence.
Possible existence and necessary
existence. Possible existence is
something that depends on something else
for it existence.
>> Correct? Correct. A a possible existence
is something that depends on something
else for his existence.
>> Like a ball moving from someone kicking
it.
>> Me I depend on something. You depend on
something. Our earth.
>> You depend on your mother and father
creating.
>> No no no no. They are my cause but I
don't depend on them to survive. They
cause me but I don't depend on them.
existence depends on I'm not even trying
to get deeper but but I don't depend on
them existence yeah but I'm saying when
we're talking about your examples right
now we're talking about you they've
created
>> they cause me but I don't depend on them
depend on my regardless of dependence
but I'm doing this on dependency not
causality so
>> yeah that's what it is but your life is
dependent on them
>> yes no right now but your life having
been created is depend the initial the
initial the initial My my my initial
creation is from them but I can be
adopted by other people as you
but let's just clarify this
>> they still were dependent for your
existence
>> initially but yeah going forward not
okay so do you agree that our planet
earth is dependent
>> yes
>> yes now is our universe dependent or
independent
>> uh I don't have enough knowledge about
this but I would say I would say from
The best of my knowledge which is
limited is independent as in the
universe existed.
>> The universe is the universe is
independent. Did you say?
>> Yeah. But that's the best of my
knowledge.
>> Okay. Good. So when you say the universe
independent, you agree that we need that
independent being. You just ascribed it
to the universe.
>> No, I don't agree that we need an
independent being. I
>> Why do we say the universe is
independent then?
>> I I believe that we can exist like uh
spontaneously. I don't think we need an
independent being.
>> No, no, one second. You said the
universe is independent.
>> Yes. So we're requiring
>> sorry if you're saying God is the
independent being why can't the universe
be the independent
>> good good before we come to that you
said the universe is independent so you
agree that we what did I say there's two
kinds of existence
>> dependent dependent independent so good
so we said I said is the universe
dependent or independent you said
independent that's good for me cuz you
agreed that they there we require an
independent thing you ascribed it to the
universe correct
>> yes but you're being very specific on my
definitions And I am not the most
educated person. So I might say
something wrong. No, it's not about
something. My my point is that I might
say something wrong right now. And it's
>> it's not about being right or wrong. I
just want to give par. I'm not here to
make right or wrong or look smart or I'm
not here to catch anyone out. I'm here
to have a discussion and learn. So the
argument I'm saying is the following.
>> If you say the universe independ
independent, there's an issue with that.
I will prove to you the universe is not
independent because number one, anything
that is composed of pieces and can be
any other way cannot be independent has
to be dependent. You would love to hear
more.
>> For example, you are made out of pieces.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Okay. Good. You can be any other
way. You can have one arm missing, one
leg missing.
>> Good. One eye missing. Good. So,
anything that is composed of pieces and
can be any other way is dependent
>> on what? Sorry.
>> No, just it's dependent.
>> Dependent. Sorry. This is not immense
attack. I'm just dependent on what?
>> No. No. That's what I mean. You are
dependent on survival like food,
shelter, etc.
>> Okay. Once again, this might be wrong,
but I'm pretty sure the definition
dependent leads to another noun. Leads
to another pronoun. Would you agree? I
can't just say I'm dependent. I'm
dependent on something. So that's not at
all an attack. It's me asking. No,
that's what I'm saying. I'm saying the
universe is composed of galaxies.
>> Yes.
>> Pieces. So anything that's composed of
pieces has to be dependent
>> on what? So that's where I ask
>> itself. Look, for example, what I'm
saying is that for example,
>> sorry, I'm so disrespectful. I not mean
to laugh.
>> No, it's not disrespectful. I'm making
an argument. Very simple. So the
universe is composed of galaxies.
>> Yes.
>> Anything that's composed of galaxies, it
depends. You can't have our universe
without galaxies. It won't be a
universe.
>> So that that means for in order for the
universe to be universe, it depends on
our galaxies.
>> The galaxies but yeah that's where I
disagree.
>> But that's like saying I'm dependent on
my bones.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Perfect analogy. You are
>> you are dependent on your thoughts or
something. Exactly. No, but you depend
on them now. We might have done this
wrong. I depend on them right now, but
I'm not dependent on them.
>> Perfectly. We might have got this wrong.
>> How are you? How are you standing?
>> I am not the on my bones.
>> No, I never said that. How are you
standing?
>> Okay. Well, then if you're going to play
that argument, then we should also be
dependent on ourselves. We should also
be dependent on the oxygen we bre to
provide energy.
>> I'm dependent on my exactly. By that
logic, we're dependent on
>> my my friend. Do you depend on your
heartbeat to survive?
>> Yes.
>> Uh yes. Yes. So that means you're
dependent.
>> Yes. But you can Thank you. That's my
That's my point. So you're dependent on
your heartbeat to survive.
>> Kind of depend no
dependency means look contingent means
something that depends on something else
for its existence. You require your
heart to be to exist.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> That's what I'm saying. Over
complicated. Good. So good. So the
universe depends on the galaxies within
it to be a universe. Yes. Otherwise,
>> it doesn't a universe consists of the
galaxies. Without the galaxies, it
wouldn't be a universe. I exist. I
agree. I agree.
>> Thank you. So now the question I'm
asking is the following. Now that proves
that the universe is not independent.
>> The universe is not independent. It is
dependent. So if it's dependent, what's
it depend on?
>> Can I just say your your meaning of
dependent has switched in between the
arguments?
>> Tell me how it's switched, please.
Because originally you were saying
dependent was dependent on something
higher. No no I said the universe is
composed of galaxies without those
galaxies universe.
>> Let me just hear further before I say
anything. I'd like to hear further.
Yeah.
>> Okay. So so if you no no about God
exists. Yeah. So just just stay with me
please. Yeah.
>> Sorry. What's your religious stand?
>> Just just no. Can we just can we just
please but I support Muslim people.
>> Yeah. We just think they atheist. We
just proven God existed.
>> I would just like to clear this up right
now.
>> So, so, so, so therefore the question is
very simple. If the universe is now
dependent, not independent like you
said, which I've proven, what does it
depend on?
>> As you said, it depends on no.
>> No, no, no. The universe holistically in
as a whole depends on something either
dependent or something independent.
>> But you said the universe is dependent
because it's dependent on its galaxies.
Yes. And then you ask me what's it
dependent on? I'm saying it's galaxies
because that's exactly
>> that's exactly what
saying perfect doesn't answer your
question with all your respect. IF I IF
I GO PERFECT PERFECT QUESTION. So now
>> what did you say the universe is
repeatable?
Anything that is composed of pieces and
can be any other way is dependent good.
Make listen
you said before the universe was
dependent. We asked what's it dependent
on. You said it's dependent on its
galaxies. No it's dependent because it
is composed of galaxies not it depends
on you said it depends on galaxies.
Looking
>> my friend my friend the part come before
the whole. Correct?
>> Yes.
>> So the uni the galaxies makes the
universe. Correct. Good. So the part
comes before the whole. So the question
is the following. Anything that is made
out of pieces and can be any other way
is dependent. The question I'm asking is
the following. The universe is it
dependent or independent? I mean sorry
the universe we know it's dependent. Now
does it depends on something?
>> Exactly. That's what I'm saying. That is
such a question that I I I just I just I
just I just proved it. I just proved it.
So So now SO NOW SO NOW I'm sorry. Can I
just say one thing? You asked us is the
univer at the beginning you said is the
universe dependent on independence. We
said independent. Then you proved it by
saying the universe is independent on
its galaxies.
The universe and now you're saying it's
dependent on not the galaxies something
else. You're you're twisting their
dependent.
>> You can disrespect as much as you want
and say we look like idiots. I I I
firstly I never said I'm here to make
you look like idiots. You're you're
you're you're
the one who every time you're the one
every time I make a point. You're No,
sorry. I didn't see I didn't see. Sorry,
sorry, sorry. I've got an eye condition.
Sorry, I can't see it. So, that's fine.
So,
>> anytime I'm making an argument, all I'm
hearing is you're like, "Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I don't understand why you're
doing that. I'm not here. Look, I'm not
here." No, no, no look no look no look
no look no look no look no look no look
no look no look. It's totally fine.
Maybe you are dependent on that the
behavior. Yeah. It's fine. It's fine.
It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. Now,
what I'm saying is this. What I'm saying
is this. Let's get back to the logical
rational argument.
I said to you, is the universe dependent
or independent? You said independent.
>> Yes.
>> Good. That works for me. You know why?
You acknowledge that we require
something independent. You ascribed it
to the universe. Are you listening?
>> Are you listening? I repeat again.
>> When when you said the universe is
independent, that's good for me. You
know why? Because you acknowledge that
we require something independent, but
you ascribed it to the universe. One
second. What I'm trying to do is the
following. I believe there is also
another an independent being cuz
remember I said to you there's two types
of existence dependent and independent.
So good. So when I proved to you that
the universe is composed of galaxies
that shows that the universe has to be
dependent. The question I asked was the
following. What does the universe depend
on? Does it depend on something that is
also dependent or rationally which one
makes more sense? It depends on
something that is independent.
>> Or what if the universe
>> does depend or independent
>> or what if the universe is independent
itself?
>> I just my friend I just proved to you
why the universe cannot be independent.
>> I PROVED IT BY SAYING IT'S DEPENDENT on
things that are in within the universe.
I you're jumping from here to here and
expecting
>> you cannot have it's called the fallacy
of infinite regress. You cannot have a
dependent thing that depends on
something else. So it's called the
fallacy of infinite regress. Simple
question. If I was to give you a £10
>> and I had to ask someone behind me.
>> No. I don't want to hear this.
>> And that went on forever, would I be
giving you £10?
>> Yes.
>> No.
>> Yes. Well, you can't just say no. When
you ask me
>> I repeat again. I repeat again.
>> If I was to give you If I was to give
you £10 and it goes
>> before I give it to you, I had to ask
someone behind me. Can I give him the
£10 if this £10?
>> Okay.
>> I have an official argument. Ask someone
to leave. I have an official argument.
Please. I
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Listen,
I I don't care. Look, my friend, my
friend, I don't care where it's going to
go. I'm not here for the cameras.
>> If I was going to give you £10, listen,
you're listening to reply, not listening
to what I'm listening.
>> Good. If I was to give you £10, but the
condition was I have to ask someone
behind me, if that chain went on
forever, would I give you the £10?
>> 100%. Tell me how£10 because you are
still transacting the £10 for me. Even
if you have to ask someone for
permission, it is still at the end of
the day you giving me 10. I think you
understand that sounds aggressive.
>> No, it's not aggressive. Let me just
repeat again.
>> I'm going to give you an iPhone.
>> You can't just repeat an argument until
I agree with you.
>> I'm making a logical I'm making a
logical case. PLEASE
my my friend my friend.
>> I've been trying to talk to you about my
friend. My friend, my friend, my friend,
my friend, my friend. I'm you're you're
being irrational. If I was to give you
this phone
>> Yes. And before I give it, I had to say,
do you give me look? No, no, no, no, no,
no, no. One second. One second.
>> One second, my friend. One second. If I
have to ask him and ask him,
get a free
Sudan.
>> Salah pro guided Matt.
>> Get it here, boys.
>> You need this.
>> May Allah get you. Just one second.
>> Key
40.
>> Are you guys ready to listen? Yes. Okay.
So, if I'm going to give you £10, but
before I give you the £10, I have to ask
someone behind me. Let me demonstrate.
>> Do you give me permission to give him
£10? He says, I have to ask someone
behind me.
>> If this goes on forever, would I be able
to give you £10?
>> Who's giving me £10? You. You are
>> with the condition. With the condition,
I ask someone behind me. And if this
goes on forever, would I ever get to
give you the Listen carefully.
>> I'm listening, bro.
>> If there isn't, it's not like you're
hearing my
>> If there isn't, please let me I'll be
I'll take 20 seconds.
>> Please. Yes or no?
>> All right.
>> No.
>> Give me 20 seconds. Wait. No. I'm saying
no. I'm saying no. As in that isn't your
turn. Please give me 20 seconds. Right.
>> Yo, Dingo, can I punch this guy right
now?
>> Who's held in court? Who's held in law
for punching you? Me. No matter who I
have to ask, no matter what conditions
it is, you're not listening. You're
arguing. You're not going. Listen to me.
Listen to me.
>> You will never get to punch me. Look,
look. You would never get to punch me,
my friend. My friend, you are not
listen. You're not listening.
>> Can I listen? Say something. No.
>> Really?
>> No.
>> Very, very, very, very rarely.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Brother, can I say something?
>> Are you guys You have nothing to drink
today.
>> No.
>> Okay. You will never get to punch me
because if the condition is that you
have to ask permission from someone and
that goes on forever. It's called the
fallacy OF INFINITE REGRESS.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT FAULT. MY FRIEND, YOUR
ARGUMENT IS BASED ON INFINITY. And your
argument is based your argument is based
on the fact of infinite time that you're
going to have TO KEEP ASKING PEOPLE that
has nothing to do with the please give
me 20 seconds.
>> All right. SOMEONE SLAP ME. I genuinely
now now genuinely I question your
rationality.
>> Please give me 20 seconds and then I'll
>> forget forget boss. My friend
>> I'm trying to be here. I
>> did I do I see anything disrespectful to
you? Good. So you're not you know what
you're doing? You are too occupied and
focused about you think I'm trying to
catch you up. I'm not. I'm trying to
have a rational discussion. I completely
>> Why are you saying Let me tell you
something. Are you guys You guys have
Have you gone to university?
>> No, I'm going to university.
>> Okay, good. My friend, genuinely,
and I don't mean this in a disrespectful
way.
>> Yes, I
>> If you take this film and show it to
your classmates, rationally logically,
they'll say, "What on earth are you guys
talking about?"
>> J, look, I'm telling you, go to your
teacher. It's called the fantasy of
infinite regress, my friend. It's so
simple. You will never give the £10 if
there's an infinite regress of asking
people for permission.
>> Ask
I'm just going to say when you approach
us cuz you're talking about us for being
uh relying on other people and relying
on not good logic. When you approach us,
you asked, do you think the universe is
independent? Do you think as creator?
That is a GCSE RS argument.
>> I don't care if you
>> GCSE or ABC. It's an argument.
>> Make an how does that make it wrong?
Okay. This argument is OKAY, ONE SECOND.
THE BUILDING IS MADE OF BRICKS, SO IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. LISTEN, LISTEN, my
friend, you have to defend your
position. I can't come and say, "Hey,
I'm not going to answer you cuz it's
GCSE. I don't give a damn if it's ABC."
>> I'm sorry. I'm not trying to
>> No, no, no. One second. It's all good.
Listen, rationally and logically, the
question is very simple. The universe is
either dependent or independent. I
proved it's dependent. What does it
depend on?
>> You didn't prove it. IT DID. YOU
ATTACKED. OKAY. NO PROBLEM.
>> YOU ATTACKED OUR ARGUMENT.
>> WHERE DID THE UNIVERSE come from?
>> Huh? Where did God come from?
>> The big bag. The big bag. The big bag is
the universe. God is independent. THE
UNIVERSE. MY ARGUMENT. THE UNIVERSE IS
INDEPENDENT.
>> WHERE'S THE EVIDENCE? Where's the
evidence?
>> What's the evidence? God is independent.
>> Thank you. Perfect. Thank you. You know
why? Because I told you there are two
types of existence.
>> You told us.
>> One second. One second. Did you guys not
agree that there is two types of
existence?
>> I agree.
>> Dependent and independent. Good. You've
talked about this. One second. One
second. One second. One second. One
second. No. No. No. No. One second.
Okay. I'll talk to you. Dependent or
independent. I've told you anything that
relies on something else for it
existence is dependent.
>> Perfect. And I said to you anything that
is made out of pieces and can be any
other way. Can the universe be any other
way?
>> Yes.
>> Good. Can you have four extra galaxies?
>> Yeah.
>> Four. Four minus galaxies.
>> Yes.
>> Perfect. Which means it is dependent.
That's a big jump once again.
>> He agreed. Look, I said to him, can
anything that can be any other way is
dependent? He goes, yeah.
>> No, you said you said does anything that
consists of parts, is that dependent? I
said, yes. Then you said I never said if
anything could be either other way, does
that.
>> Good. Okay. Now ask again.
>> Can God be any other way? Question to
you.
>> No, it can't be any other way.
>> No.
>> Thank you. That's my point. Any other
way? Why not?
>> Because he's necessary.
>> Because he's necessary. The universe is
>> because good. No, it's not because the
un
one sec. You said the universe
necessary. Yeah. Okay. Can there be less
galaxies in the universe? So dependent.
>> So it can't be necessary. Why can't God
be the can be any other way? Thank you.
>> Can God Can
you understand? Can God have one finger?
>> God doesn't have a finger.
>> There we go. Galaxy. Thank you. Do you
see the universe is composed of pieces?
It can be any other way, you know. No,
it's No, it's not.
>> Why? How? How? Wait, prove to Can you
prove it? Prove to me.
>> Prove to me the prove to me and read it.
>> Wait, wait, wait. You know, you know,
you know, you know what it is, bro. We
don't do that. You know, you know, you
know, you know, you know, no one. You
know, you know why you're behaving like
this. You know why you're doing this?
Because you guys are too focused instead
of following the truth. No, no. Instead
of the truth, you are too focused on you
think I'm trying to catch you out. I
PROMISE YOU. AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
DISCREET WITH MOST RIGHT NOW. I'M I'M
SAYING something come from nothing.
>> Please, please answer my question. My
Tik Tok. I've got a I've got a debating
channel. My uncle runs a debating
channel. I will happily debate you.
>> No, I'm debating now.
>> No, I will happily debate you.
>> You debating?
>> Well, can something come from nothing?
>> I'm
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> Can something come from nothing? Can the
big bang Can the big bang exist?
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> Which is what you're getting at.
>> Yes.
>> Where come something come? Something can
come from nothing.
>> Yes.
>> When you're on about science,
>> do you know do you know what? Do you
know what nothing is?
>> Do you know what nothing is? What's the
definition of nothing?
>> Nothing.
>> No. Nothing.
>> No. The absence of something. The
absence of something. Now, how can the
absence of something come from? One sec.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. One second.
One sec. One second. One second. One
second. One sec. One second. One second.
One second. One second. My friend, can
something come from nothing? You said
you said yes,
>> brother. Brother, brother, please don't
get involved.
>> You I said, can something come from
nothing? You said what? Yes. Prove it to
me, please.
>> Where did God come from then? Okay,
>> brother. You're jumping the question.
I'M ASKING YOU.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO. Answer this. We'll
come to who created the God. Now I'm
going ask you a question. Can someone
come from my
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Please,
please, please, just hear me out before
like, okay, let's say I try and answer
this and I fail, then your
>> I don't care about failure.
>> Okay, but wait, please,
>> let's say answer this and fail. Your
ultimate argument is going to be that
God created. Where did God come from
then?
>> Don't worry about my argument. Answer
the question. We'll come to that. Can
something come from nothing? You said
yes. Show me how.
>> Can something come from nothing? Where
did God come from then? I I know this is
going to sound.
I'm asking you. Can something come from
you? That's the point of something
coming. It's irrational. If Einstein was
here, he would run for his life.
>> Einstein will say something. ZERO CAN
EQUAL ONE.
>> HAVE YOU DONE MATHS?
>> I know. I
>> have you done maths? Can zero equal one?
>> Where did God come from,
>> my friend? We will come to that.
We will know. You're running out. You're
running. You're running. You know why?
CUZ YOU KNOW YOU'RE INTELLECTUALLY YOU
KNOW YOU GOT INTELLECTUALLY DESTROYED.
>> We're both going to shut you
intellectually.
>> Wait. Wait. We're both going to shut up
until good came from.
>> Perfect. Good. No, no, no, no. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. You said the
universe can come from nothing.
>> Talk about you, not me.
>> Talk about you.
>> How?
>> Talk about you. Where did God come from?
>> No, no, no. I'm asking you. You said
something can come from nothing. Prove
it, please.
>> And we've tried to explain that and we
said in order to in order to debunk our
thesis, you need to you need to explain
your thesis.
>> You don't answer a question with another
question. Where did how could something
come from nothing?
>> The whole point is how could something
come from nothing? It's it's it's
irrational. Where did God come from?
Where did God come from?
>> My friend, I'm asking you about the
creator creator. You're you're you keep
because you can't because you can't
answer yourself.
>> How could something answer your own
question?
>> HOW COULD SOMETHING COME FROM THAT? Look
how many people are actually.
>> Can I just say you can't answer your
own?
>> How can something come from asking me
the same question over and over again?
>> You're going to get clip. YOU CAN'T
ANSWER. THAT'S ALREADY DONE. That's
already finished. Listen, I'll be
honest. This you guys are going to be
the most irrational people I've smoked
in my life.
>> Can you answer my question? No, because
you haven't answered my question.
Listen, my friend. Something cannot come
from nothing. So, if something cannot
one second, one second, one second. If
something cannot come from nothing, that
means the universe was created by
something. Correct?
>> Where did God whether that something
COME FROM?
>> I REPEAT. GOOD. PERFECT. NOW, the
universe began to exist. It didn't come
from nothing. We have four
possibilities. It either came from
nothing. Hear me out. The universe, the
big bang. Yeah.
>> Okay, good. There's four possibilities.
>> Yes, I'm listening. The universe came
from nothing.
>> The universe popped by chance.
>> The universe was created by something
that is created.
>> Or the universe was created by something
that is uncreated.
>> Okay.
>> Do you accept those four clauses?
>> No. Because Okay. First, exactly. I was
going to say first two were the same. If
it was created by chance or was created
by nothing, either way nothing
will.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I repeat
again. Even the universe came from
nothing. Even the universe was infinite
always there. Either the universe was
created by something else that is
created or the universe was created by
something uncreated.
>> Okay, so it's three
>> four four. So let's go one by one.
Universe created from nothing. Universe
was always there. Universe created by
something that is created.
>> Universe that was created by something
uncreated. Good. First one. Now the
first one. Can the universe come from
nothing?
>> Uh what's your definition of nothing?
Absence of something. Okay. So
absolutely like genuinely nothing.
>> No.
>> Yes.
>> Then then well this is separate. We're
not the same people. We have different
arguments.
>> No. What's yours? What's what's it?
>> When you talk about absolutely nothing,
>> my friend is such an EASY ANSWER, MAN.
>> I KNOW, BUT you're kidding me.
>> Okay. Okay. Please, let's not be
disrespectful. We have a crowd of 40
something plus people.
>> My friend, who cares? I'm not Look,
look, brother. Brother, I'm not here for
these people. I don't give a damn about
what they think. I'm here for the truth.
>> Okay. Nothing.
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> Yes. And that's why I say yes. Prove it.
Prove it. Okay. Prove that God. If you
prove it, prove option four. If you
prove it, I'm going to become an
atheist.
>> Prove option four. Prove option four.
Can I say one thing? Look, look. We're
going to go through them one by one.
He's jumping, my friend. The first one
is can it come from nothing? Let me say
this.
>> Can look. You said it can come from
something. Prove it. I said it can come
from nothing. Prove God comes from
nothing. And then as soon as you answer
that, I'll get on my knees.
>> You've been talking about infinite
regression. Yes. The infinite
regression. Have you been talking about
that? Yes or no? Okay. So, if you keep
infinitely regressing, I could say, so
you're saying the universe came from
something. If you keep infinitely
regressing, where did that came from?
That I've just turned your whole
argument against you, my friend. I have
infinity.
>> Exactly. It's a fallacy. Exactly. You
just said it's a fallacy.
>> Do you agree something come from
nothing?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Prove it.
>> What do you mean prove it,
>> my friend? If you say, where did the
universe come from? That's what we're
trying. Where did the universe come
from?
>> I had four options. We're going through
them one by one. What's your option?
>> The look. The first one is that it came
from nothing.
>> You're trying.
>> So, no, no, no, no, no. My friend, prove
to me, you said silly questions that you
can't ask yourself.
>> My friend, my friend, my friend, my
friend, my friend,
>> can you can you can
>> Where did God come?
>> Can you guys go there? My My friend, my
friend.
>> No one can answer. No, no, we can. I
can. I can. I can. You are afraid to
answer this cuz you know you don't make
sense.
>> You can't answer it and you can't
>> I can I can my friend. That's the reason
why I gave you four options. You're
afraid to answer this. Can come from
nothing.
>> Unanswerable. I'm saying I can't answer
to where the universe came from. No. You
can't answer.
>> Can it come from nothing?
>> Huh? Yes.
>> Prove it.
>> Prove where God came from?
>> No. Can God come from nothing?
>> You're intellectual bankrupt.
>> Can God come from nothing? Can I tell
you something? A 5-year-old will know
better than you,
>> my friend. He's bro. Look, he's a clever
man. Can something come from nothing,
brother?
>> From nothing.
>> From nothing. Thank you, bro. Man, look,
you know, forget this, bro. Can
something come from nothing?
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> Yes. From nothing. Something come.
>> No. No. No. Bro, let's ask. You know
what? Forget this guy. Let's ask the
crowd, brother. Can something come from
nothing? Can something come from
nothing?
>> I I don't speak English.
>> Okay, that's English, brother. Can
something come from nothing? Look, look,
I swear to God, I would ask everybody.
Look, look, look, I'll ask him. What's
your name,
>> brother? can suffer come from nothing.
>> Ah, no. Never.
>> Thank you,
>> brother. It's simple. Lo,
>> brother. Brother, brother, brother.
Well, like I tell you, I swear to God,
if I stop the 5-year-old, they'll say
no,
>> brother. It's a logic, you know. Zero.
Zero cannot kill one.
>> Something that started.
>> Thank you, bro. Thank you.
>> Going to go back.
>> No, not that. NOT EVEN THAT, BRO. He
can't answer it. Thank you. Thank you.
Okay, no problem. Let's stop someone
random. Let's stop someone random. NO,
NO, NO, NO. STOP RANDOM. You stop
someone. You stop someone. Okay, you
stop someone. You stop someone. Okay,
stop someone. Stop it.
>> Okay. No, no, no. One sec. One sec. Stop
anyone. Anyone,
>> my brother. Now, now you're completely
out the window. You're trying to You're
trying to embarrass. No, I'm not. No,
I'm not. No, I'm not. Don't try it.
Don't try it. You're trying to stop. I'm
going to stop someone. YOU'RE TRYING TO
stop someone and ask a rational
question.
>> And what what are you going to say?
>> Point of the argument. I'm going to stop
someone. I'm going to stop someone. I'm
going to stop someone. Come. Let's stop
someone. Come. Go.
>> No. No. Be here. Let me let me stop
someone.
>> Excuse me, sir.
Let me see someone English. Yeah. Can I
ask you a question?
>> Do you speak English? Can I ask you a
question,
>> my friend? Can I ask you a quick
question?
>> Oh, no. I'm good. Thanks.
>> Can I ask you a quick question? Just a
simple logical question.
>> Watch this now. Yeah. Watch this, bro.
Just look. Watch and see. I'm going to
stop someone random.
>> You're going to ask? No. No. You're
going to ask on purpose. You're going to
ask. No, I'm not. You're going to ask.
Not even me.
Hello. Can I ask you a quick question?
>> I'm going to stop somebody and we're
going to ask them something so simple.
Can something come from nothing?
>> If they have rationality and logic,
they'll say no.
>> And then and then I'm going to ask them
where God came from.
>> My friend, I'm not even talking about
God. I'm saying can something come from
nothing.
>> What did God COME FROM?
>> MY FRIEND, I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT GOD.
>> YOU BEING A TALKING ABOUT GOD. BREAKS
YOUR WHOLE HEART AND YOU'VE BEEN MY
FRIEND MY FRIEND my friend my friend my
friend I'm not even talking about God
I'm asking a very simple question
>> something come from nothing
>> thank you go to the mental hospital bro
>> go to a mental hospital bro look I stop
someone my friend can I ask you a quick
question
>> can I ask you a quick question
>> thank you brother what's uh are you
religious
>> no
>> are you a what are you atheist what or
agnostic
>> nothing simple Simple question. Simple
question. Simple question.
>> Can I ask it?
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> That's my argument as well.
>> Can you prove it? Something can come
from nothing.
>> He's asking, "Can I prove it?" But when
when I ask him, "Where does God come
from?" He can't answer.
>> Perfect. No problem. Now, watch this.
You believe something can come from
nothing. Yeah.
>> Okay. Can you show me what that is,
please?
>> What?
>> Can you demonstrate to me? Tell me what
is one thing that came from nothing.
>> Exactly. He's asking you an impossible
question. You're asking an impossible
question. You're embarrassing. JUST A
RANDOM MAN. HOW DO YOU FEEL? You're
embarrassing random man street by
asking.
>> Be quiet and let the man answer.
>> Sorry.
>> Have some respect.
>> Have some respect, man.
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> You don't.
>> We'll see. You said yes.
>> Can you tell me what can come from
nothing?
>> Every time I speak, it comes from
basically nothing. Right.
>> So, it doesn't come from your tongue and
you talking your vocal cords.
>> So, your vocal cords are nothing.
I mean the idea to speak.
>> No, no, no. Nothing is the absence of
something. Nothing means zero. Can zero
equal one?
>> Nope.
>> Thank you,
>> my brother. You're changing and changing
the question to embarrass these people
by asking them an impossible question.
>> So, thank you for your honesty. Zero
cannot equal one. THAT'S MY WHOLE POINT.
ALL I'M SAYING IS THIS.
>> Zero cannot equal one. Thank you. Do you
Thank you very much. Thank you, brother.
He's just shaking my hand, man. What do
you mean? No. No. Thank you. Zero. Can
you come? What? Man, go to school, bro.
>> Go. I'll ask another person, my friend.
Can I ask you a question?
>> He's asking impossible question.
>> Good question. Just Okay. Can something
come from nothing?
>> No. Like absolute nothing. Something
>> in theory? No.
>> Thank you. Can zero equal one?
>> I don't know. It can. It might be able
to. It might not be able to.
>> Zero. Can it ever equal one? like 0 plus
0 plus 0 could ever make one.
>> That's not what we're asking.
>> One second. I'm asking I'm talking to
Can you Can you let the guy speak?
>> If you add something to it. Yeah.
>> Thank you. But if you don't
zero,
>> thank you.
>> Thank you. Can I ask you now? Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
>> Hello. Can I ask you a question?
>> Quick question. Can I ask you a quick
question?
>> What's your name, madam?
>> Arena.
>> Arena. Can Do you think something can
come from nothing?
>> Can something come from nothing?
Exactly. I'm sorry.
>> Do you do can you speak English?
>> No.
>> Okay.
Thank you.
>> Ukraine.
>> How you doing, brother? Are you a
Muslim? Christian?
>> Uh, Christian.
>> Christian. Okay. He's a Christian.
>> Can we go back to him?
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. My brother, my friend, can
something come from nothing?
>> You're avoiding.
>> Can something come from nothing?
>> Thank you, man. Thank you, man.
>> My brother, you're avoiding it.
Look, let's see what he has to say.
Let's see what he has to say.
>> I want you to expand on what you mean.
>> Perfect. Perfect. Something. Okay.
Nothing is the absence of anything.
Nothingness. In that nothingness, can
you get something?
>> Well, it depends.
>> I want more context in terms of what?
>> It's very simple. The absolute
nothingness, not atoms, nothing. Zero.
Can you get something from that?
>> If there's completely nothing. Yeah,
it's completely nothing. I want you to
know I want to know what it's what
you're trying to correlate to.
>> I'm not calling nothing. I'm just saying
it's completely nothing. Can you get
something?
>> But you're going to use his answer in
the context of a question,
>> my friend. One second. Very simple. In
the absolute of nothingness, can you get
something?
>> I need the I need the context,
>> my friend. I just gave you the context.
>> No, you haven't.
>> Absolute nothingness.
Can you get something out of that?
>> If it's absolute nothingness, no.
>> Thank you. But I want to know what
>> that's No, that's it. You mean thank
you.
>> No, IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT. OKAY, GOOD.
GOOD. What's your name, brother?
>> Morgan, let me use the argument with
you.
>> We say the universe began to exist.
>> Yes. That's where you're trying to get
from.
>> Thank you. Now, there's four
possibilities. Now, there's four
possibilities. There's four
possibilities.
>> There's four possibilities. It either
came from nothing.
>> It either was always there.
>> It either was created by something else
that's created or it was created by
something uncreated. Does that make
sense?
>> I believe there was something before.
>> There wasn't nothing.
>> So, so, so good. Good. So, you believe
that it was always there?
>> Infinite.
>> I would say it's infinite, but there was
something there.
>> Okay. Okay. Either he came from nothing.
Either he was always there. Either he
was created by something created or he
was created by someone created.
>> He was always there. Does that make
>> sense? Thank you.
>> He was always there.
>> Completely wrong.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Go back to school, mate. Go
back to school.